how we got engaged and who proposed to
whom
exclusively we
got engaged in the
most beautiful way that I could have imagined
could exist because it was the house
there in your grandmother's house in a part
of the uppermost part of the
building  and I did not expect it and you
told me come I want to show you a place I
want to take you a place I want to take you
a place I want to show you and I followed
you thinking in the most innocent way Ah come on let's go
maybe you started looking for something and I
thought what  It happens to him and how come you didn't
take it out
like it was locked and I thought he
was looking and what hit me You
knelt down I think if you're nervous
So I don't remember all the
details either but you knelt down I think and
then since he's on his knees looking for
something in his pocket  I thought
why are you doing that to him I
can't believe it, it's not like he's going to give me a
ring So you gave me a ring and that's
how we got engaged